[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
les accords d'evian c'était il ya 60 ans
ces accords de paix signés le 18 mars
1962 à evian ont mis fin à la guerre
d'algérie après pratiquement deux ans de
tractations secrètes un cessez le feu
est entré en vigueur le 19 mars la
guerre d'algérie ses huit ans de conflit
entre 260 milles et quatre cent mille
morts côté algérien trente mille côté
français et plusieurs dizaines de
milliers chez les harkis cette guerre a
laissé des séquelles psychologiques et
politiques en algérie et en france elle
pose la question de l'état de la mémoire
ou plutôt des mémoires autour de ce
conflit mais aussi des questions
politiques sous la responsabilité de la
france emmanuel macron à engager un
processus de réconciliation des mémoires
inspiré des recommandations de
l'historien benjamin stora le président
français a honoré la mémoire des harkis
il a reconnu que le mathématicien
maurice audin étaient morts de torture
du fait du système institué en algérie
par la france alors quel est l'état de
la mémoire ou des mémoires autour de ce
conflit quel est l'impact de la
politique mémorielle d' emmanuel macron
qu'en pensent les jeunes les jeunes
français ou algériens on va en débattre
avec mes invités j'ai plaisir l'avait
d'avoir avec moi à paul max moras un bon
soir vous êtes chercheur au cevipof est
également enseignant à sciences po
auteur de les jeunes et la guerre
d'algérie c'est aux puf également
co-auteur du podcast sauce algérienne un
podcast produit par spotify à partir de
témoignages notamment de descendants de
familles d'immigrés de pieds-noirs
d'anciens soldats dans ces harkis et de
juifs d'algérie bienvenue à vous en face
de vous slimane zeghidour bonsoir
écrivain journaliste rédacteur en chef
tv5monde chercheurs également associé à
l'iris sur les questions du proche et du
moyen orient auteur de sorts la route tu
attends mon village en kabylie 1954 1962
et c'est à paris les arènes bonsoir à
vous et bienvenue également avec nous
monde amumu bon soir fondateur de
l'association agir pour une juste
intégration juste intégration dans la
république ancien membre du haut conseil
à l'intégration
auteur notamment d'un livre ils sont
devenus harkis et c'est chez fayard
bonsoir à vous et bienvenue également en
face de vous monadia eni moulaye bonsoir
vous êtes auteur et entrepreneurs des
médias hauteur de un rêve deux rives et
7 aux éditions slatkine et compagnie on
a également avec nous par skype justin
perez bonsoir à vous petite fille de
pieds noirs qu aux tris et productrice
avec d'ailleurs pôle max - qui est avec
nous présent du podcast fameux podcast
sauce algérienne un podcast disponible
donc sur spotify les accords d'evian ce
sont donc des accords de pêche je disais
signé le 18 mars 1962 à evian signé
entre le gouvernement français à
l'époque et le gouvernement provisoire
algérien ils ont mis fin à la guerre
d'algérie en tout cas il ya eu un cessez
le feu qui est entrée en vigueur le
lendemain le 19 mars accessible
tu leur a fallu des mois de négociations
secrètes préalable et l'accélération des
attentes à alger et à paris début 1962
pour qu'enfin après huit ans d'une
guerre meurtrière s'ouvre officiellement
les pourparlers déviant le 7 mars 1962
entre le gouvernement français et la
branche politique du fln
la conférence dure 11 jours et les
pourparlers butent notamment sur deux
dossiers
l'avenir de la communauté française
résidant en algérie son sort ne sera
finalement pas réglée par l'accord et la
question de la souveraineté du sart
paris exigera et obtiendra de conserver
pour plusieurs années la mainmise sur la
région où les intérêts français
pétroliers y nucléaires sont importants
le 18 mars 1962 les accords d'evian sont
signés avec un cessez le feu qui doit
prendre effet le lentement à midi le
soir même le général de gaulle s'adresse
aux français mais les déclarations
gouvernementales
la perspective qui s'ouvre sur
l'avènement d'une algérie indépendante
coopérant étroitement avec nous
satisfont la raison
dans les faits les violences
continueront de longs mois low as
l'organisation armée clandestine
constitué par des partisans de l'algérie
française multiplient les attentats le
fln répliquent par des assassinats et
des enlèvements d'européens soupçonnés
d'être proches de l'organisation
mais le processus d'indépendance prévues
par les accords d'evian est inéluctable
dans un contexte de tension le 1er
juillet 1962 la population se prononce
par un oui massif en faveur de
l'indépendance de l'algérie
elle sera proclamé quatre jours plus
tard le jour même d'un nouveau bain de
sang le massacre d'oran
insécurité et violence entraîne l'exode
de près d'un million de pieds noirs vers
la métropole dans les bateaux se trouve
aussi quelques 10000 a requis des
supplétifs de l'armée française
ceux restés en algérie sont souvent
victimes de représailles
un rapatriement douloureux dont les
blessures se font toujours ressentir
aujourd'hui
le max moras est ces accords d'evian
c'est une bifurcation de l'histoire un
changement d'ère ben oui c'est une
rupture non seulement c'est la fin de la
guerre d'algérie mais ça ouvre aussi la
fin de 132 ans de colonisation française
en algérie donc effectivement c'est une
rupture c'est une rupture bien sûr pour
l'algérie qui devient indépendante mais
aussi pour la france qui va se séparer
de de l'algérie qui était qu'ils étaient
trois départements français donc ça va
entraîner des transformations majeures
institutionnelle puisque on va on a
changé de république pendant la guerre
d'algérie mais aussi identitaire puisque
la manière de se définir comme français
ou de définir la france va profondément
être de transformer avec cette
indépendance puisque on va voir la
france un peu ce
resserrée sur un espace européen avec
aussi des influences en termes de
recomposition identitaire sur une
identité française + + france plus
européenne plus blanches plus chrétienne
alors qu'avant elle se pensait beaucoup
plus mondial aussi avec la colonisation
ça c'est des impacts majeurs ça va avoir
un impact aussi démographique puisque
l'indépendance de l'algérie va entraîner
l'arrivée ou le retour de millions de
personnes qui ont vécu en algérie et qui
vont refaire leur vie en france que ce
soit les descendants d'immigrés de pieds
noirs de harkis comme on l'a entendu
dans dans le reportage et qui vont
fonder des familles seaman zéguédoua
vous êtes franco algérien né en algérie
vous avez vécu cette guerre vous étiez
enfant votre famille a été placée dans
un camp de regroupement qui a été créé à
l'époque par l'armée française en
algérie et quel est votre souvenir de
cet accord de cessez le feu vous en
souvenez oui une séquence très précises
c'était un matin faisait très beau mais
un peu frais et j'ai vu passer au dessus
du camp de regroupement aux étions un
petit avion qui avait lâché des petits
bouts de papier j'ignorais ce qu'était
qu'un vous appliquez l'âge j'avais 8 ans
et demi et donc les gens se précipitent
pour aller ramasser ces bouts de papier
et dans le pâté de barack et de
paillotes où nous étions j'étais le seul
qui savait lire donc quelqu'un est venu
me donner un petit bout de papier donc
je me faisais je ne réalisais pas
l'enjeu de la faire n'est-ce pas parce
que dans le camp de regroupement nous
n'avions pas de poste transistors nous
ne savions pas vraiment ce qui se
passait donc l'indépendance on ne savait
pas quand est-ce qu'elle allait arriver
toujours est il je prends ce bout de
papier et je commence à épeler
scrupuleusement chaque lettre et j'avais
lu que 16 le feu toutes les lettres je
les avais prononcer eh bien avec tout le
monde avait compris j'ai senti tout de
suite une clameur une explosion de joie
autour de moi qui m'avait un peu surpris
et surtout surtout mon père qui était un
homme très très réservé je n'ai vu
soudain se lever et commencé à danser
comme un fou c'était la première et la
dernière fois de ma vie où je voyais mon
père dans ces mondes amumu alors vous
êtes fils de harkis pour vous cette date
elle est quoi synonyme d'exode forcé
comme vous savez cette date elle pose
toujours question parce qu'effectivement
elle est censée être
la fin de la guerre d'algérie elle est
historiquement mais pour les pieds-noirs
et pour les harkis c'est le début du
calvaire c'est à dire que le cessez le
feu n'a cessé que d'un côté et après le
19 mars malheureusement il y avait plus
de morts du côté des harkis et des
civils après le cessez-le-feu qu'avant
ceux qui postent cette question
effectivement de commémoration et encore
moins de célébration du 19 mars c'est un
des premiers livres d'ailleurs que vous
avez sorti justement sur cette histoire
qui rompt le silence parce qu'elle met
le silence autour de tout à fait c'est
le livre et ils sont devenus art qui
était issu d'une thèse que j'avais fait
l école des hautes études et
effectivement jusque là il n'y avait pas
eu de travaux scientifiques peu sérieux
je crois que c'est une oeuvre qui reste
pionnière parce qu'il fallait expliquer
pourquoi certains sont devenus harkis
parce que pour les enfants ça pouvait
paraître incompréhensible et c'est en
remontrant la complexité de cette guerre
fratricide et civiles à bien des égards
en montrant aussi que elle s'inscrit
dans un humus historique qu'au fond on
peut comprendre comment des personnes
d'origine arabe ou berbère qui n'était
pas contre l'indépendance parce qu'ils
avaient conscience des inégalités du
système on arrive à devenir a requis
pour différentes raisons parce que là
aussi vous reviendra peut-être tout à
l'heure je dis larguerait dollar qui
n'hésite pas à tancer pour ça il y avait
des gens qui avaient jusque étaient des
gardes sont derrière derrière le terme
de l'art qui aujourd'hui on englobe en
fait à la fois des notables musulmans
comme les bachagha à les caïds à la fois
des militaires de carrière depuis des
générations
et puis des des paysans qui sont devenus
harkis parfois pour s'occuper des saints
pour aider et des fois dans les unités
combattantes mais c'est très varié
effectivement nadia et nîmes ou là vous
vous êtes franco algérienne et c'est
votre grand père qui faisait partie lui
du fln vous revenez dans votre dernier
livre sur son parcours qu'est ce qui
vous a dit sur ces accords d'evian alors
c'était pas mon grand père c'était mon
père votre père dans la nuance est
d'importance et la nuance est importante
les deuxièmes générations vous êtes dans
la deuxième génération alors moi j'ai
aucun souvenir qui me parlait des
accords d'evian c'était une dot que
j'avais apprises à l'école qui était un
peu lointaine pour moi en revanche après
avoir publié mon livre qui est sorti en
septembre dernier j'ai repris contact
avec le mont frère aîné que je n'avais
pas vu depuis très longtemps et il m'a
raconté
la fin de la guerre donc cette date du
cessez le feu et qu'il était dans un
café parisien avec mon père parce que
voilà les cafés algériens étaient très
longs en fin étaient très nombreux à
paris et il disait que c'était une
ambiance de effectivement de fait et il
se souvient d'un oiseau qui est venu se
poser sur sa tête donc c'était peut-être
une métaphore de cette paix même si
aujourd'hui elle et elle est contredite
par certaines personnes justin perez
vous êtes avec nous par skype vous vous
êtes petite fille de pieds noirs donc
troisième génération ci ne me trompe pas
pour les pieds noirs à l'époque c'était
aussi l'exode vers la france comment au
sein de votre famille on parle justement
de ces accords d'evian
effectivement mal non plus on n'en parle
pas en fait le 19 mars et pas rester
comme une comme une date
particulièrement dans ma dans ma famille
en fait on a peu parlé de la guerre
d'algérie
et on a peu parlé de l'histoire
familiale en lien la guerre d'algérie en
revanche on m'a beaucoup parlé du
rapatriement et je pense que finalement
les accords d'evian pour eux ça marque
véritablement j'allais dire le retour
mais pas du tout leur tour l'arrivée
dans un territoire qui ne connaissent
pas en fait ce qui est qui et la
métropole et qu'il découvre voilà il
découvre la france finalement ni l'eau
dès qu'ils décrivent comme une blessure
oui effectivement ils ont ils l'ont
décrit comme une comme une blessure
comme un accueil compliqué
ça a été compliqué de venir d'algérie
d'arriver en france aussi parce que ils
ont l'impression de devoir lisser leurs
particularismes culturels d'un coup il
fallait arrêter de parler arabe arrêter
de parler pâte à oued qui était la
langue vernaculaire voilà créé en
algérie avec des bouts de d'espagnol un
peu d'italien un mélange comme ça qu'ils
parlaient tous les deux non ils avaient
l'habitude dans la rue en algérie et l'
arrivée en france s'est impliqué aussi
voilà se séparer en fait de cette
culture algérienne pôle max moras 7
millions de personnes
d'après ce que vous dites ce que vous
écrivez en france ont un lien personnel
ou à titre familial lié à la
décolonisation en algérie donc qui est
noir on a vu immigrés militaire a requis
donc ce sont en fait des histoires
singulières des mémoires différentes est
ce qu effectivement il ya une guerre des
mémoires non pas du tout c'est déjà ça
représente énormément de personnes
effectivement puisqu'il ya 39 % des
jeunes qui ont entre 18 et 25 ans
aujourd'hui qu'on un grand père ou une
grand mère qui a été affectée par la
guerre d'algérie donc c'est énormément
de personnes effectivement pour les
personnes qui n'ont vécu il ya eu des
expériences historiques différentes mais
ce cloisonnement des mémoires que l'on
décrit souvent ils ne se prolonge pas
dans les nouvelles générations non la
troisième génération la halle un match
de la très grande majorité des jeunes
descendants ont une vision finalement
assez consensuel de se passer là ils
vont avoir un regard critique sur la
colonisation légitime et l'indépendance
avoir un regard bienveillant sur
l'ensemble des acteurs
et peut-être que l'histoire familiale va
déterminer certains contenus ou la
formes que peuvent prendre certains ici
mais par contre le jugement sur le passé
s'est déterminé par l'orientation
politique mais ça c'est vous à partir de
la troisième génération d'un troisième
génération la ya peut-être plus
d'apaisement qu'est-ce vous voulez
peut-être réagir et slimane zeghidour là
dessus oui je suis d'accord qu'il n'y a
pas de garder mémoire c'est inconscient
des mémoires
de benjamin stora me semble qu'il ya une
réalité au mieux les mémoires oui ou non
il y a des vécus différents plus que des
mémoires il ya des vécus ya des récits
différents et il y a des souvenirs
différents par exemple moi j'ai grandi
dans un camp de regroupement
où nous étions totalement coupés du
monde puisque ce camp était entouré de
barbelés nous étions surveillés par des
tirailleurs sénégalais des légionnaires
il y avait des harkis mais tous les
bidasses étaient eux des infirmiers ou
des instituteurs nous ne savions pas ce
qui se passait à l'extérieur par contre
un algérien comme moi de l'époque qui
était en ville lui il pouvait regarder à
la télévision et pouvaient écouter sur
la radio la voix des arabes depuis
l'egypte ont la voix de la radio du fln
depuis tunis où le maroc ils pouvaient
savoir ce qui se passait mais nous
c'était juste la guerre est finie on est
retourné dans notre village après cinq
ans d'absence on n'a pas reconnu le
village a été envahi d'herbes sauvages
où l'armée avait enlevé les fenêtres et
les portes et nous sommes retournés dans
des gourbis complètement fantone et
c'est là que nous avons compris nous
avions compris qu'il était impossible
désormais de retourner à la vie d'avant
parce qu'on avait goûté à l'école et à
l'infirmerie et c'est pour ça que quand
des millions d'algériens nous sommes
allés vers les villes pendant que les
français les quitter j'ai vu un
chassé-croisé incroyable à alger des
gens qui partaient à l'aéroport pendant
que nous nous arrivions donc des
mémoires tout de même très différente
emmanuel macron en tout cas engagé un
processus de réconciliation ce qu'il
appelle en tout cas une sorte de
processus de réconciliation des mémoires
inspiré des recommandations de
l'historien benjamin stora le président
français a honoré notamment la mémoire
des harkis on m'a reparlé il a également
reconnu que le mathématicien maurice
audin étaient morts de torture du fait
d'un système institué en algérie par la
france on va l'écouter tout de suite
emmanuel macron
au nom de la france je dis aux harkis à
leurs enfants à voix haute et solennelle
que la république a alors contracté à
leur égard une dette
aux combattants
je veux dire notre reconnaissance
nous n'oublierons pas
aux combattants abandonnés à leur
famille qu'ils ont subi les camps la
prison le déni
je demande pardon
nous n'oublierons pas mon amour nous
vous étiez cette cérémonie est
d'ailleurs vous en aviez parlé ici même
sur ce plateau et vous me disais que
c'était une étape importante pour vous
oui oui c'était un moment important
j'avais même eu l'honneur de prendre la
parole avant le président de la
république c'est quelque chose qu'on
demandait depuis longtemps dans un
article paru dans le monde en 2018 qui
s'intitulait ce qu'un président pourrait
dire j'avais dit premièrement demander
pardon deuxièmement
faire une loi de reconnaissance ou et
troisièmement effectivement mettre en
oeuvre la réparation
avait suffi en tout cas le faim dont ça
vous avez suffit qu'ils pardonnent ne
pas aller plus loin que cela je pense
qu'on peut dire que si ça suffit on peut
dire que c'est très important évidemment
il ya des choses qui peuvent paraître
impardonnable il ya des choses qui
soient irréparable c'est pas une raison
pour ne pas demander pardon après ceux à
qui ils s'adressent malheureusement 90%
ce sont morts donc je sais pas si lui
pardonneront toi je trouvais que c'était
un geste extrêmement courageux parce que
jusqu'à présent aucun président de la
république avant lui ne l'avait fait il
y avait eu de la compassion il y avait
eu des mots de nicolas sarkozy quelques
jours avant les élections de monsieur
hollande mais il n'y avait pas eu de
demande officielle de pardon il le dit
d'une voix forte et solennelle à
l'elysée je trouve que c'est quand même
un pas très important car max moras
qu'il s'agit justement une sorte de
ligne non à la repentance mais oui à la
reconnaissance est ce que c'est que ça
c'est ça le bateau moi justement
derrière maman là en l'occurrence est
inverse puisque le partons c'est de la
repentance alive ses champs lexical de
la religion peut alors que la
reconnaissance c'est un travail
politique est là pour le coup c'est vrai
que et nicolas sarkozy et françois
hollande avait avait reconnu là le sort
l'abandon des harkis et la manière dont
ils avaient été accueillis en moins
facile on peut parler d'accueillir en
france dans l'après 62 moi je pense dans
le discours de emmanuel macron il manque
justement deux choses qui rejoignent ce
que de ce que disait mon collègue tout à
l'heure c'est qu'on ne peut pas
comprendre comment ils sont devenus par
harki ça on ne comprend pas dans le
discours et on ne comprend pas non plus
pourquoi ils ont été traités comme ça
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés en france et
vous le disiez tout à l'heure ces deux
écrans de la définition de l'identité au
moment de re du rapatriement c'était une
identité beaucoup plus judéo chrétienne
et que les musulmans ne faisait pas
partie exactement de la nation c'est
pour ça que les rapatrierons tu le titre
officiel de rabot didier et les harkis
on tue le titre officiel de réfugiés
mais ce qui était non pas du tout je
voulais jamais de man en armes ils
n'étaient pas considérés comme des
rapatriés sous le même statut que les
autres ils n'ont jamais eu de titre de
réfugié ils n'étaient pas des rapatriés
du général de gaulle voulait surtout pas
précisément une et elle avait rapatrié
comme les autres c'était pas sur le même
statut cette aide et rapatriaient mais
simplement effectivement d'origine arabe
elle n'avait pas bénéficié des mêmes
système d'insertion france hésité dans
des camps ce n'est pas le cas de zona
mais là c'est autre chose mais quand on
dit qu'ils ont été appelés réfugiés non
ils n'ont pas été appelés à réfléchir et
c'est effectivement il non non ça j'en
suis sûr par contre effectivement ils
n'ont pas été traités de la même façon
simplement parce que disait mon collègue
non moi je pense qu'effectivement c'est
pas de l'arpa ton repentance au sens
religieux demander pardon c'est demander
pardon parce qu'on reconnaît justement
qu'on a fait un certain nombre de choses
qu'on n'aurait pas dû faire ou qu'on n'a
pas fait ce qu'on aurait dû faire donc
c'était très important de reconnaître
cette responsabilité de l'état parce que
c'est à partir de cette responsabilité
de l'état que peut s'engager une logique
de réparation si vous n'avez pas de
reconnaissance de responsabilité et de
préjudice si on n'est pas dans la
réparation on est au mieux dans
l'assistanat nadia et nîmes ou là et
vous liez algérie non mais je pense ça
serait intéressant de dézoomer un peu
effectivement il ya le drame des harkis
et en même temps ce qu'on en parle tout
le temps de la mémoire réconcilier de sa
fin c'est devenu un slogan fait la
réconciliation des mémoires mais moi il
me semble bien que il ya quand même 7 à
8 millions de personnes issues de cette
histoire faim qui ont un lien direct
avec cette en direct avec cette histoire
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on ait une
guerre civile en france je pense qu'on
peut quand même s'asseoir autour d'une
table et discuter est-ce que ça ce jour
était pas là non mais c'est ça moi en
tout cas je parle de mon point de vue en
2022 avec mon expérience de française
dont française donc né en france issus
de l'immigration algérienne avec un père
fln est très engagé au fln ce que je
veux dire c'est que je
crois pas que ce soit les mémoires qu'il
faille réconcilier les mémoires ce sont
les récits des familles on peut pas les
enlever aux personnes que ce soit des
familles de harkis des familles de juifs
d'algérie de rapatrier cetera de gens du
fn on peut pas enlever c'est sur ces
lignes les narrations familiale donc
encore une fois moi ce que je pense
qu'on élude comme toujours le fond du
sujet qui est l'origine
cette histoire le drame des harkis a une
origine c'est pas la guerre d'algérie en
tant que tel c'est pas la colonisation
c'est la conquête en fait et on évacue
toujours toujours les faits dans ce
débat en fait dans ce débat politique et
emmanuel macron à bien c'est vrai qu'il
fait bouger quand même des choses il a
été un peu plus volontaires que les
autres il y ait du sens politique
aujourd'hui sur la reconnaissance de la
responsabilité de l'état français par
exemple assez c'est ça on a tjrs un
drogué mais c'est autre chose mais la
coexistence au quotidien des 10 des
français
descendants de harkis aux descendants de
membres de l'oas ou descendants de
combattants du fln ou descendants des
appelés c'est une existence au quotidien
qui n'a absolument aucun problème
moi je vis depuis 47 ans hurle sur dans
l'hexagone jamais gêner la moindre
occasion de la moindre friction avec qui
que ce soit à propos des rancoeurs ou
des haines de la guerre de la guerre
d'algérie pourquoi parce qu'on le sent
trente deux ans il y eut les
expropriations la haine le bon bah les
bombardements quête la nuit oui mais il
n'y a pas eu que ça il n'y a pas un
algérien qui n'a pas eu son quart
d'heure d'un métier avec un français
d'algérie c'est à dire que l'inégalité
juridique sur le quotidien n'interdisait
n'est les bons rapports amicaux n'est le
bon voisinage nil en trad et c'est pour
cela que c'est un tout c'est un bloc ses
132 ans c'est un blanc coup il y a eu le
pire mais il y a eu aussi des moments
d'humanité
lui la journée la situation première
place alors ça
c'est rien la lutte veulent aujourd'hui
venez en france et sont heureux de vivre
la vie taxer pas fait contre la france
en tant que telle elle s'est faite
contre la colonisation et la france
coloniale la dernière et ça c'est très
important parce que encore une fois ce
que les parents nous ont transmis c'est
pas la haine de la france il ya
peut-être ce mythe qui voudrait que dans
les familles algériennes issus de
l'immigration humaine de la france
placés faut jamais en pour deux mois
dans les camps j'ai grandi c'est là mais
entendu ce prix qu entre les français et
ensuite frère
vit pas sur la même planète
tout simplement très simplement on voit
bien que emmanuel macron a fait
effectivement beaucoup de gestes en
direction de l'algérie en face il ya
aucun geste enfin s'il ya toujours la
haine de la colonisation de la france et
des
je vous ai pas pensé déterminez vous
répondrai que
tu as tout à fait raison slimane il faut
faire une différence entre les
gouvernants et le peuple algérien mais
aujourd'hui les gouvernants algériens
continuent à répandre entretenir cette
haine de la colonisation de la france et
des harkis pour masquer la faillite du
système la réalité elle est là le
problème c'est que ce qui est appris la
gemme instaura me le rappeler avec
justesse il me disait mais tu sais c'est
pas si simple parce que les enfants sont
nourris aussi avec une histoire
falsifiée en algérie l'affection ne mord
pas sur le respect et quand tu regardes
quand tu regardes ce qui s'écrit sur les
réseaux sociaux quelque chose ça et je
te dire qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
tensions mais quand vient la phase i
mais le souvenir qu'en passant même
temps elle hésite on va dire que ce que
vous êtes en train de dire est une
vérité la vérité c'est en fait at il
parlé de ce mémorial
juger mon sujet c'est comment la france
qui est un pays dans lequel j'ai grandi
qui est un pays avec plein d'idéaux qui
a été un phare pour beaucoup de pays
comment cette france elle règle cette
question de la colonisation de ce
qu'elle a fait en algérie et pas qu'en
algérie il n'ya pas eu que l'algérie il
ya eu madagascar il ya eu là la kanaky
n'y a pas eu que l'algérie donc moi
c'est ça mon sujet parce que si on est
toujours en train de se dire oui mais
attendez en france on veut bien faire
des efforts mais ça va dépendre de ce
que va faire l'algérie on n'avancera
jamais mais justement il y mène 5-2 voix
a demandé sur cette question de la rente
mémorielle du côté justement des
autorités algériennes alors du côté des
autorités
du discours officiels algériens il n'y a
pas une histoire de la guerre d'algérie
qui fasse consensus déjà il n'y a pas de
rendement national qui soit accepté par
tout le monde l'a vu pendant il ya une
rhétorique il ya une rhétorique qui se
veut patriotique qui se veut un peu
revancharde et glee beaucoup plus
incantatoire qui story syst c'est à dire
et qui restait là même toutes ces années
4 en 1982 pour les 20e anniversaire de
l'indépendance le journal l'hebdomadaire
algérie algérie actualité on était à 20
ans 20 années seulement de
l'indépendance avait fait un sondage
pour demander à des jeunes ou avaient
été conclus ou avait conté avait été
conclu les accords d'evian seuls 20%
c'est ma mémoire est bonne avait répondu
la ville d'evian les autres en citer
d'autres villes c'est à dire qu'il y à
beaucoup plus un discours incantatoires
qu'une vraie connaissance de l'histoire
et c'est un mec mémorielle ou parce que
des macros c'est vrai ce qu'une rente
mémorielle peu importe la formule mais
on n'est pas dans l'histoire n'est pas
dans l'histoire justin perez vous qui
êtes petite fille de pieds noirs est ce
que vous voulez réagir à ce que vous
venez d'entendre justement sur ce
travail de mémoire est ce que chez vous
il ya un conflit de mémoire est ce que
vous pensez effectivement qui a tout de
même un conflit entre les différentes
mémoires celle des harkis celle des
algériens celle des pieds-noirs
nom est alors particulièrement pas au
sein de la troisième génération et je
pense que c'est réellement ce qu'on a
voulu faire dans le podcast social géré
yen s'est au contraire de passer parler
de toutes ces familles mémorielle là est
de montrer que finalement les
trentenaires ou laisse cette troisième
génération de petits enfants 2 n'était
pas du tout dans une gare des mémoires
et vivait très bien les uns avec les
autres je veux dire on ne s'oppose pas
qu'on soit d'un bord de la guerre
d'algérie à un autre ou que nos grands
parents aient appartenu à un bord de la
guerre d'algérie ou à un autre il faut
voir aussi que la majorité de ses grands
parents l'ont été en fait ballotter par
l'histoire je veux dire il ya aussi
énormément de rapatrier qui juste
n'avait pas participé particulièrement à
la guerre d'algérie ils ont été voilà
ballotté au gré des décisions politiques
d'état
donc non je pense qu'il n'y a pas de n'y
a pas de conflit et que ceux qui y voit
un conflit le fond aussi volontairement
c'est à dire que politiquement il ya un
enjeu à venir remplir ce vide de la
guerre d'algérie dont on parle
finalement peu ou mal à venir le remplir
avec des clichés des stéréotypes une
opposition de la société voilà à monter
les uns contre les autres c'est beaucoup
plus facile d'être dans cette rhétorique
belliqueuse puisque elle permet de
fédérer alors justement slimane
zeghidour juste également avant de
revenir sur la jeunesse parce qu'on va
terminer cette émission sur vraiment sur
la jeunesse il a honoré également mm
macro les mémoires des descendants du
migration algérienne en qualifiant de
crime inexcusable pour la république les
fameuses tuerie commise à paris en
banlieue par maurice papon donc à
l'époque contre justement des
sympathisants du fln qui
manifestaient contre le couvre-feu ça
c'est une avancée aussi ou pas des
manuels macron c'est important de faire
politiquement oui oui parce que en fait
ce que c'est très important d'autant
plus que ces manifestants étaient sur le
haut sur le mmm ont juridiquement des
citoyens français
donc on a imposé un couvre-feu sur une
base ethnique c'était déjà une violation
de toutes les valeurs de ce pays donc
cette reconnaissance évidemment ne va
pas ramener les morts mais elle est très
importante elle met du baume au coeur
sur leurs dessins sur de leurs
descendants donc cette idée de
reconnaissance encore une fois il ya un
chemin pas politique a continué de bien
sûr mais en fait ce qu'on ne rappelle
pas cessé que ce que fait emmanuel
macron il le fait dans la continuité de
l'état français c'est à dire qu'au
lendemain des accords d'evian le
gouvernement français avait commencé
archos il y est les français c'est pour
ça qu'il y réussisse loi d'aministie
n'aime les assassins dès qu'ils ont
voulu tuer ceux qui ont voulu tuer le
général de gaulle ont été amnistiés
jusqu'ici emmanuel macron travail art
concilier les différentes factions des
héritiers des différentes factions de la
guerre d'algérie ce qu'on aimerait c'est
que du côté algérien on entame aussi une
réconciliation à l'intérieur de
l'algérie
entre algériens entre les descendants de
yamana et ceux du fln c'est ce travail à
l'intérieur de l'algérie qui n'a pas
encore été ce qu'est un malentendu entre
justement emmanuel macron est
aujourd'hui son homologue en algérie sur
cette question puisqu'il n'y a eu que je
dirais rupture diplomatique
emmanuel macron a aussi peut-être été un
peu ambigu sur cette question de l'accès
nation algérienne qui a fait beaucoup
réagir de poser
la question sur y avait-il une nation
algérienne en 1830 ça franchement de la
part de chefs d'état c'est une
discussion dans un département de
science politique pourrait donner lieu à
une à une discussion passionnante
d'ailleurs en 1830 la belgique venait à
peine de naître l'italie n'existait pas
l'italie n'existe que depuis 1870
l'allemagne aussi la plupart des nations
d'aujourd'hui la pologne l'ukraine
n'existait pas comme nation donc par
contre les algériens mais la nation
algérienne était complet nation c'est
une formation historique ce n'est pas
une entité organique je fais ce que je
veux dire ce qui est rendu furieux une
partie de l'opinion algérienne avec
cette question c'est que l'ethnographie
coloniale le discours colonial fendait
la légitimité de la présence française
sur une inexistence d'une nation
algérienne ils diraient ils disaient on
venait dans une terre nul donc on n'a
violé aucune souveraineté nationale
c'est pour ça que ça ça avait suscité
secours ou en algérie et nadia et nîmes
ou là et vous vous dites dans un article
récent on peut être anti colonisation et
ça veut pas dire qu'on est anti france
donc vous voyez bien tout de même les
oppositions les antinomies entre les
termes absolument mais c'est important
de le dire moi je suis française je suis
né en france donc je suis aussi
algérienne mais je suis né en france
j'ai un parcours français j'ai grandi
dans un quartier je suis allé à l'école
de la république donc il s'agit pas de
s'auto flageller comme certaines
personnes ont tendance à dire en gros
mais de reconnaître les faits un mois
sur cette question encore une fois de la
mémoire pour moi c'est du langage
politique c'est un slogan politique qui
permet encore une fois de ne pas parler
du fond du sujet la question ce sont les
faits qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
algérie à partir de là qu'il faut aller
plus loin justement à l'élégance de ses
fers sur la colonisation ah parce que
l'histoire
d'algérie on parle toujours de la guerre
d'algérie ce sont huit années il ya eu
132 ans de colonisation il s'est passé
des choses pendant ses cent trente deux
ans la guerre d'algérie c'est la fin
mais il faudrait se plonger dans cette
période coloniale a été fait par les
historiens
historiens les historiennes 6 mai nadia
a raison c'est le travail enfin le le
mot clé c'est pas réconciliation c'est
le travail à un moment il faut organiser
le travail il faut donner des moyens aux
chercheurs et aux chercheuses il faut
créer des chaires universitaires
justement les archives sont elles
ouvertes ça c'est facile on peut revenir
sur son histoire familiale sur
l'histoire de l'algérie aujourd'hui en
france c'est beaucoup plus facile qu'il
ya 30 ans et sur la société elle s'est
ouverte elle progresse
les archives ont été ouverte il ya trois
générations outre les archives bas ont
presque là il reste encore bien des
circulaires mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que moi je me permets juste par
rapport à mon travail de romancière
quand je suis allé chercher dans les
archives concernant le passé de repères
donc tu es au fn je découvre
effectivement qu'il a été
un homme de main du fln qui l'a fait
partie des troubles de chaque est ce que
je fais de cette histoire qu'est ce que
je fais je la raconte je la raconte pas
gelé racontait il ya aussi une réalité
c'est que c'est pas forcément facile
d'assumer ça parce que il ya toujours
cette suspicion quand on est français
issus de l'immigration issus des
quartiers etc etc de se sortent cette
sorte de procès en loyauté donc
effectivement vous êtes vous m'aidez le
faire au départ ah ben je voulais le
faire parce que parce que j'ai jamais
écrire parce que j'ai ça dans
j'ai très vite que mon père avait un
parcours romanesque et aussi parce que
de toujours dire oui mais attendez vous
n'avez pas connu la colonisation
vous êtes vous de quoi vous parlez bah
oui c'est vrai que j'ai pas connu la
colonisation j'ai vécu dans un quartier
j'ai grandi dans un cocon plus tôt j'ai
pas à me plaindre mais c'était plutôt
d'alger dont parlait pas vraiment la
falémé tabou c'est que moi j'ai grandi
avec un homme donc mon père qui avait
quand même des traumas et qui avait une
violence que il nous a transmise et ça
c'est une réalité donc oui je n'ai pas
vécu la colonisation mais j'en passe
vous aviez le besoin d'aller rechercher
justin que vous êtes dans la même
démarche que nadia et nîmes ou là
justement qui est sauf que vous êtes
vous petite fille donc c'est la
génération d'après mais d'abord être
démarche d'aller questionner vos parents
vos grands parents sur cette histoire
pour exactement moi je souscris
totalement à ce que j'aime bien nadia
c'est c'est difficile de se voir opposé
à un procès en illégitimité quand on n'a
pas vécu directement la guerre ou
l'histoire de la colonisation
est en réalité on a hérité des
souffrances on a hérité des traumas on a
hérité des douleurs alors certes à des
degrés moindres c'est différent aussi
selon les familles mémorielle moi par
exemple j'ai jamais vécu de racisme
c'est pas voilà c'est pas écrit sur ma
peau non plus que j'ai un lien à cette
histoire là en revanche le fait d'avoir
une construction identitaire un peu
étrange avec une histoire qu'on connaît
mal et qu'on découvre sur le tard ça
c'est réel des relations qui peuvent
être parfois complexes avec les porteurs
directe de cette histoire là donc les
grands parents c'est aussi le cas et une
volonté surtout d'enquêté en fait de
mener à bien des quêtes puisque on en a
besoin pour pour avancer pour se
construire est avancé mais on va les y
voilà c'était juste pour réagir parce
que effectivement on a besoin de
connaissances historiques parce que
pendant très longtemps on a tu cette
histoire parce que cette histoire gêné à
la fois la france gêné l'algérie pour
les harkis par exemple que je connais le
mieux la france parce qu'elle a
abandonné les harkis l'algérie parce
qu'elle a massacré des dizaines de
milliers et qu'elle n'a pas voulu
reconnaître pourquoi certains étaient
devenus arqués mais le problème c'est
qu'il ya une vraie dissymétrie en termes
de recherche de la vérité c'est à dire
autant en france il ya beaucoup depuis
20 ans une vingtaine d'années de
chercheurs de livres autant en algérie
je suis désolé sur certains pans de
cette histoire sur les harkis sur les
messalistes on n'écrit pas encore cet
abri et un autre élément aussi c'est que
il ya des des retombées indirectes de la
guerre d'algérie c'est que c'était quoi
le problème algérien c'est qu'il y avait
une population musulmane dans ton se
poser la question depuis la 3ème
république 1870 peut-on être musulman et
français et elle a été résolu par
l'indépendance aujourd'hui à l'époque la
france intégrait le territoire de
l'algérie mais pas des algériens
aujourd'hui à la relance et aux
territoires et elle a des descendants
d'algérie en france intègre donc ça
devient une question identitaire en fait
oui parce que jusqu'à maintenant la
question de débat sur l'islam utilise
l'arsenal du vocabulaire de la garde qui
était qui avait cours dans l'algérie
coloniale
le fait de continuer à douter d'eux est
ce qu on peut être musulman et français
alors que les gens sentent déjà des
français outre le côté obscène de cette
question c'est que les descendants
d'algériens se sentent se disent avant
nous étions des sujets français
aujourd'hui nous sommes des français est
sujet à caution c'est de cette névrose
qui est des deux côtés qu'il faut sortir
par le haut parce que les descendants
d'algériens ici ont inscrit leur vie
dans l'histoire
française et c'est pour ça que la
démarche de mc ren est une démarche qui
parie sur l'avenir apple mac sont
rapidement c'est c'est en fait
d'identité en ce dont vous parlez du don
n'est plus seulement dans le conflit des
mémoires ou les mémoires mais dans
quelque chose d'identitaires les gens
ont une histoire donc forcément ça a un
impact sur leur identité ça veut pas
dire qu'ils vont en faire des
revendications identitaires mais on
comprend bien quand on écoute freeman
que on a besoin de comprendre ce qu
était la colonisation est ce qu'elle a
produit pour pouvoir comprendre notre
monde d'aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui viennent de là
donc il faut qu'ils aient un message
politique qui suivent en fait le travail
des chercheurs des historiens sur
justement j'avais il a fallu deux
organisations n'y a pas eu de
clarification morale et politique sur
notre rapport à la colonisation
aujourd'hui la colonisation fait encore
débat politiquement il ya des gens qui
la défendent en disant que c'était bien
qu'ils aient tant de la réhabiliter qui
pensent que la france a fait l'algérie
etc etc c'est ce qui le conflit
politique il est là c'est pas accompli
mémorielle sens du conflit politique sur
notre rapport à la colonisation et à ses
conséquences je peux pas laisser ça va
vite moi je ne vois personne aujourd'hui
qui veut réhabiliter avant eric zemmour
il fait pas ça
juste ne pas
nommer aujourd'hui je veux dire il ne
faut pas confondre le système colonial
qui est qui est injuste et tout le monde
le reconnaît mais la colonisation mais
elle existe depuis que le monde est
monde je veux dire les romains ont
colonisé tous et pas les mêmes mais je
ne comprends pas manitoulin
c'est le terme les pays tous les pays où
les grands pays ont beaucoup que le
disait et personne aujourd'hui ne
justifie
la domination d'un peuple sur un autre
simplement dans le cas de l'algérie
c'était une colonisation de peuplement
ce qui était un peu différent et
justement ce que les pieds noirs je
pense pas que j'entends pas de pied
mardi à la colonisation c'était bien je
dirais l'ailier l'indépendance étaient
des dictats pour tout le monde
simplement pour autant ils veulent qu'on
reconnaisse aussi que ces gens qui ont
vécu là bas pendant quatre générations
ont pu aimer ce pays et lui à voilà
alors évidemment vous dire ce différend
n'a plus beaucoup de temps en 2005 on a
failli avoir un article de loi dans la
loi de porter à connaissance à la nasse
je le connais bien rapatrier où on
parlait de desbiens fait positif de la
colonisation donc pas si loin que ça
ira aussi ça a pu apporter aussi des
apports positifs envoyés en témoigne en
tout cas les désaccords qui n'aurait de
toute façon
pas noël domination maure donnez moi il
nous reste 20 minutes juste un petit
quelques jeunes justement qui s'exprime
sur le sujet et on conclura avec ça avec
un tour de table mais on les écoute on a
tous notre biais on a tous notre
position on a tous notre compréhension
personnelle intime de cette mémoire mais
on est aussi rassembler autour de
valeurs et d'idées communes il faut bien
comprendre que nous sommes tous dans un
esprit de réconciliation de paix et
d'apprentissage on aimerait maintenant
élargir le cercle que d'autres jeunes
nous rejoignent donc on a mis en place
des réunions publiques pour ça il ya
tellement de gens qui sont concernés par
cette histoire par ses mémoires que
c'est dommage de passer à côté de cette
réflexion collective
il faut qu'on les connaissait
effectivement modestement de l'entamé
mais après c'est à chacun de s'en saisir
un petit mot alors de conclusion à dire
justement je pense que deuxième
génération deuxième génération est
rejeté dans un centre social dans un
quartier pour présenter mon livre et on
me demandait ce que cette histoire et
comment la racontent aux jeunes je
mangeais répondu à cette histoire-là
quant aux jeunes quand ils ont envie de
qu'on leur raconte c'est à dire quand
ils commencent à s'interroger sur ça
mais par dessus tout au delà de la
réconciliation des mémoires je pense que
c'est la république qui doit se
réconcilier avec elle même avec ce
qu'elle a été ce qu'elle a dit être est
ce qu'elle a fait merci beaucoup ça sera
le mot de confusion c'était un débat
passionnant trop court donc on en
reparlera merci d'avoir été avec nous un
pôle max moras merci à vous membres
amumu merci slimane zeghidour merci
nadia eni là ils merci à vous juste une
période où il était avec nous par skype
merci à vous tous deux heures suivis et
reste avec mon propre carte